у
я і на більшакова тренер міжнародного
проекту jit вони і тому для розвитку
критичного мислення я хочу познайомити
його зі стратегії розетку критичного
мислення до спадання та до успішного
хрестові керчі це лям збагатив околиць
кольору за крима на Україні багато
по-чеськи та школі місця криво розумні в
руках кубок створений елемент для
реалізації стратегії автор я декого на
кований у 1980-му уроки старої вчися на
таксономії світло них цілий бенджаміна
блума розроблений скуп цієї
розряду осередку дуже тата зібраний тему
кубиком можна кор залишатися вона буде
вам уроки з щитків та школі голи
потрібно розглядаючи кейсі об'єкт шия
ваще на уроках української мови
допомогою кубика можна створити текст
опуси aptx приміряння кубок у роті
засовує пеклу розряду чого ще дуже
добрий знає для загальна не я їх
знань і виявив і не так званих темних
місць але ще для ти не сказала судити
чому я процес нічого не знаю чи право
на сиджу до тієї необхідної інформації кубок
можна висновок про цю саму стильну суп
кого картону про обклеювання коробку за бенкетом
кубок пошита з конини вінду шлунка і
з ручні про розлучення на корені і
грані куба написано в козявки вкусити
хлопець айті встановіть суті ati і про
аналізу і ти знайти застосування за
пропан ці аргументи за обидва ти
формулюйте за харчування для дуже
початкова та школи можна в коростові ти та
не шукай слова вона програти замість
пушитися
і акція вигляду та й заздрість з'являється
почнеться схожі, а взуття дражнячи це
заздрість та кісти би ви не каюті so they
прорахунки бентежить а вдома ти шпалери
кислого спадає на будинок ляльок і ти чуєш
і назад цьому заздрість про аналіз і
можна задатися забуто ні з чого дарма
ну
зазнач знайдіть розуму застосування як
ніби і цілі гори 100 а помітно води
аргументи за і проти
з доброї нісенітниці ну як ти ставиш сядуть
слова та чому на уроці 4 потрібного волосся
цю тему для письма та power that i
кубику сима грані ми через
вже не записують свій будинок до видного
роззяв на гранях куба продажів 2 3 флейт
десь може записувати ідеї на мала
частина творить цікавий текст, а може по
стільникове шоу крім слова слова з
отримання лікування після розведуть і бузу
sex турин 4 потрібно дати годину на
прочитування тих думав що написання ті
лісового тексту та заявлені теми
давайте по ріверу йому я гидкий наш
кубик розгадаєте
акваріум поголена йому кубок його ph
огранювання безодень і 4 просить учнів з
ти за зовнішній вигляд акваріуму так я
комуни з приймаєте його зате допоможуть
органі трохи на цю роботу чотири
року 2 3 волини злегка ватою за годину він
дуже важливо булочнику ви не читаєте
відразу чомусь його конова ти
створення непотрібного та магате провідних
від знайомого результату до тесту напиши
два слова полюванням старий дуже і головне
ще все дуже розумний і ще видно їх
вимагаєте на перших уроках застосування
до спадання вчитель може за пропан його
ти дуже розумний спосіб цієї так
допоможете їм зарин туго тася а тато якщо
це ще означає
про пасати предмет на папороть заняттях
, для піт козак може бути так і травень і
колеру акваріум деякого розміру по
хлопець говорити з чим ви його парі поза
це і до і форми, і гривень треба так
взятого матеріал з рубаної power to
йому кубок
і на стоп на грані парі вніте для
розуміння акваріума земним об'єктом 4
можна за пропанової св
а може краще ти вже ніхто його про
процесі появи двох об'єктів гіди
молитви і ці характеристики пройти
внесені загадав і оскільки ванни і
старий пам'ятними краще usb і став і не з
іншими об'єктами на приклад по ременя це
акваріум то клітку для up the hill 4
може за датою петелька, нас же
переніс на акваріум то клітини для
поганих навислими дражня і ти акваріум
так легко для таких поголені йому кубок
і наступна грань встановити associati та
4 просіть дуже назвати і слова та keys
падаєте їм додому ляльок його ночує слова
акваріум і тут на небо
у попереку сказати і дітям чумні гени
правої її суть 14 травня розуміє ще
освітить знімаєте особливості з нею характер
там я хочу дуже не назвав це слово
акваріум асоціацію диван то просто
попросіть їх поясні чому 2 ну а
ще вона не зможете зрубати і не
вимагає поясними деки асоціацій з
площадку на сам для себе вчення
може пояснити процес запасу
асоціації дуже і починати аналізу вати
новела знака об'єкту та його дилерські
жінки об'єкта маяки висвітилося
процесі нелінійного асоціативного
мислення
доступна грань про аналіз це вчитель
пропана я дуже проаналізувати і
будова акваріумів до його крім
частими сама ж заробити за допомогою
таких самих , скажіть congencis рубль і
назика частим складу і ти і всі деталі
знає точну відповідь можна
сформулювати і таке за харчування вам на
вивіску та ціна ти а ви можете вигода ти
доступна гра не знає і засмоктуванні 4
просить дуже і написати їхала кор
втомлюватися акваріуми
cool і акваріум потрібно для кого провини
його живим чим можна вас його бі-бі-сі
тег вона може старту троянди років харчування ж
можна ви росстат і акваріум на і запр
значенням я до самої ну і повстання грань
за пропан його ти аргументи за і проти
4u потрібного за кращу ти учень до
написання владних суддів з приводу
теми за добрий че поганом від і акваріум
правильно члени правильно вранці від його
не umud var і тепер можна
сформулювати , як виставлять і cidade
овочі люди навички ростові акваріуму для
вранці його неї відвари
поїсти нічому варіанти вид перемоги дітей
може бути і різьбленими
важливі в ще шкірний найкращий ви славу свою
владну думку за і проти
за приклад можна в їх чад і риб про
ти рибам краще жид і про природні
водоймищах за акваріуму припиняє житло
проти акваріума вимагатиме багато часу
езус або для обслуговування то ви стирчати
багатої електроенергії за акваріумом про
зорі
можна постріляти з-за рибками про ти
акваріум щирі і можна розбудити це
парад нато і селам до ми ті стратегію
можна засовувати і поспішала класу а ви
для 6 річкових porsche та класники прикрасив
брат і дві другі грані куба
розробляючи скрабом та призначаємо якусі
кубок для розряду теми сонце на корені і
зберігати його куба на моїй сливі і
маленькі за цим і можна з здогадалися
про їх значення сонечку шукає
сонечку сонечку то пайовик поміняйте
сонечку
і пайовик у сили сонечку з розумні
розвинути аргументи добрий че недобрий
коли світати пасти ну сонечку і
для кого і кому потрібні сонце наші
мужики
дити може за посадкою абу проговорить
своєю думкою
ви хрестовий ти стратегію до спадання
сидять і по сатани тільки
каліграфічно букви навколо і записувати
влада не думкою